so joe biden finally wanders out to the
microphones and he begins and i have to
say
i was shocked
shocked by his appearance
and
he has looked as though he is falling
apart for a long time he looked barely
warmed over
he sounded awful he was stumbling over
every word he was utterly incoherent
it was
it was as though he had just escaped
from a nursing home
it was it was an amazing visually
speaking optically speaking it was an
amazingly embarrassing moment
here's the president this is what it
sounded like when the president of the
united states remember this is the day
13 american service members were
murdered by terrorists
on his watch because of policies he
created and instead of him coming out
there
and looking strong and tough
instead of him coming out there and and
looking as though our enemy should be
afraid of us he looked beaten he looked
defeated he looked not just old but
decrepit here was joe biden yesterday
a tough day
this evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about and
worried about
that the intelligence community
has assessed uh has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
took the lives of american service
members
that's how he opened
that was his opening
and that alone america's enemies must be
drooling
over this over this person they must be
over the dead horse that we've thrown
out there
and then he moved on in his speech to
paying tribute to the service members
but he couldn't help himself he had to
then brag about the effectiveness of
this evacuation mission
he's still using the talking points from
48 hours ago you remember about 48 hours
ago the administration started moving on
from the talking point of this is a
brilliant idea to our evacuation has
been shockingly successful you know with
the afghans falling from the wheel wells
of planes onto the tarmac you know the
evacuation is actually like we deserve
credit
yesterday the dnc was sending out emails
bragging about how successful this
evacuation was
which as i said on the show is the
equivalent of the captain of that
titanic not accidentally hitting the
iceberg deliberately looking at the
iceberg saying i'm gonna ram this sucker
directly into the iceberg the boat
starts taking on water he rushes up to
the top deck
he unleashes the lifeboats he says
everybody in the lifeboats two-thirds of
the people get out and he says what an
unbelievable captain i am i have set the
guinness book of world records record
for the most people evacuated from a
lifeboat
okay that is what the administration has
been doing so he's paying tribute to the
service members yesterday who deserve
all the credit in the world but he can't
help himself praising his own mission
here
these american service members who gave
their lives
it's an overused word but it's totally
appropriate here we're heroes
heroes
who've been engaged in a dangerous
selfless mission
to save the lives of others
they're a part of an airlift an
evacuation effort unlike any scene in
history
with more than 100 000
american citizens
american partners
afghans who helped us
and others taken to safety
again that's him praising his own
mission
it's him praising his own mission
which is a failure
and then joe biden did what the media
loved when he does he did the empathy
thing right and by empathy it means that
he he he he tried to speak to what it
feels like to be in this you know what
none of those families
would be mourning their sons and
daughters today
none of them if it had not been for this
man's policies
so
i wonder how many of them really want to
hear it from the presidents of the
united states
but this is what he was elected to do he
was elected to empathize not to proceed
with good policy not to protect
americans because we're gonna leave at
the very least hundreds probably
thousands of americans and green card
holders behind enemy lines he was
elected to emote he's the emoter in
chief and so here he was last night
trying to paper over his gross
incompetence and malpractice
with a bit of uh with a bit of
sentimentality
we have some sense like many of you do
what the families of these brave heroes
are feeling today
you get this feeling like you're being
sucked into a black hole
in the middle of your chest
there's no way out
my heart aches for you this is utterly
instance
i'm sorry it is
you are responsible for that policy
you're responsible for like i'd love to
hear from the members of the military
families as to what they feel because
there are 17 million people who've
served in the american military over the
over the course of time who are live in
the united states right now 800 000
people have served in afghanistan proper
and i've talked to many many afghan
veterans afghan war veterans over the
course of the last
several weeks
i can't name one of them who wants to
hear emoting from joe biden as he
proceeds to to sully their legacy
subject all of their allies to the
threat of death from the taliban and now
to actual death at the hands of isis k
okay then joe biden had to uh make
excuses for the taliban right so here's
part of the policy part of the policy is
now just as it was with the iran deal
with the obama administration that once
you make a deal with the devil you have
to make excuses for why the devil isn't
actually the devil now joe biden is
making excuses for the taliban so
remember the entire incentive structure
for the taliban to protect americans as
they leave is that if the taliban don't
we might stay and retaliate against them
mitchell biden has removed all of that
by making excuses for the taliban
because he has to cover his own
political ass in case the taliban turn
out to be the bad guys we know they are
so here he was yesterday blaming isis k
but relieving the taliban of
responsibility that was the important
thing
over the past few weeks
i know you're many of you are probably
tired of hearing me say it
yes
we've been made aware
by our intelligence community
that the isis k
an arch enemy
the taliban
people who were freed when both those
prisons
were opened
has been planning a complex set of
attacks on the united states personnel
and others
this is why from the outset
i've repeatedly said
this mission was extraordinarily
dangerous
and on why i've been so determined to
limit the duration of this mission okay
so our mushmouth president then makes a
mush-headed
argument this is his argument all the
way through if bad things happen in
afghanistan because we took the cork out
of the bottle then clearly they would
have happened if we hadn't take the cork
out of the bottle that is the argument
so if
if we did x and y happened then
certainly if we had not done x y
definitely would have happened but way
worse
i'm sorry but your counter factual no
longer applies you did x and y happened
and it was perfectly predictable that y
would happen so by the way he's now
making excuses for why we should cut and
run so there is a bombing it kills
americans instead of him saying we're
going to stay long enough to get every
american citizen out and if you touch us
we will kill you
which is what any normal american
president would say his argument is look
something bad happened yesterday that's
an excuse for us to get out even faster
it just shows why we need to get out
super fast
okay then joe biden says we uh we're
going to complete the mission okay but
of course he has defined the mission as
getting out by august 31st the timeline
is the mission for joe biden normally
you define the timeline
on the back of what you need to
accomplish normally if i
decide that we need as a company to
achieve a certain thing we then say how
long will it take to achieve this thing
and then we define the timeline by what
we are seeking to achieve in this
particular case joe biden defined the
timeline and the mission is now the
timeline which means a lot of people are
going to get stuck over there here is
joe biden trying to make excuses for
this
we can and we must complete this mission
and we will
and that's what i've ordered them to do
we will not be deterred by terrorists
we will not let them stop our mission we
will continue the evacuation
i've also ordered my commanders to
develop operational plans to strike isis
k assets leadership and facilities
we will respond with force and precision
at our time at the place we choose in a
moment of our choosing okay that part is
the best part right so he says we're
going to get him we're going after him
we're going to
sometime
in the future
later
when i want to
not right now
that's what that means
that means isis just killed americans
and they're going to get away with it
because guess what in three days
okay it is now the 27th in three to four
days we are gone we do not have any
assets on the ground we do not have any
allies on the ground we don't have eyes
on the ground
okay all this talk about how we are
going to go after the isis he
he's hoping you forget that's what's
going to happen here
if that's what he's hoping
of course he wasn't going to say because
for him to retaliate now means you need
more troops on the ground not fewer
so instead he's just doing this we'll
push it off you know we'll get them at a
time it sounds strong it is actually
weak
obviously
okay and then he just tells a series of
lies that are meant to make you feel
comfortable but better just lies
here's what you need to know
these isis terrorists will not win
we will rescue the americans
nope
we will get our afghan allies
nope and our mission will go on nope
america will not be intimidated nope
has four direct lies in i mean five
actually in a row the isis terrorists
will not win they already have you
handed them kabul we will rescue the
americans in there you're not
we haven't been doing large-scale
extraction missions two rescue americans
in there and you've already admitted
hundreds if not thousands of americans
will remain after we leave we'll get our
afghan allies out nope you just handed a
list of them to the taliban so the
taliban can go shoot them and kill their
families our mission will go on nope
your mission is over in four days
america will not be intimidated too late
you jackass
too late
you're the president of the united
states babbling nonsensically like a
mental ward patience about how the
taliban are our friends now
okay there's more of this okay it didn't
stop it didn't stop and by the way we
haven't even gotten to the series of
lies that led up to this because that
this man is a damned liar and americans
are dead because this man is a liar and
thousands of americans and american
green heart holders are stuck under the
auspices of the taliban because this man
is a fool and a liar and a disgrace to
his office all right so president
biden's lies and foolishness didn't stop
last night halfway through his little
address
he continued along these lines he he
tried to blame everybody except for
himself so as we'll see later he tried
to blame trump but he blamed his
military commanders by saying it's you
know we were all unanimous on this um no
you weren't and we have information
suggesting your military commanders were
basically all warning you back in
february march that this was going to
happen and you ignored them because you
are a nitwit here is our
nitwitted president of the united states
there's been complete unanimity
from every commander on the objectives
of this mission
nope
unless by unanimity on the objectives of
the mission you mean you told them
exactly what you wanted to happen and
how many troops they could have to do it
and then they had to somehow scramble to
make that happen for you okay so joe
biden concludes his speech and again
so much of this was optic as well if you
watched it in real time
he's just not there he's not there i
won't even say that the lights are on
but nobody's home the lights are not
even on several of the light bulbs are
out there was the president of the
united states it was an embarrassing
display last night
may god bless you all my god protect his
troops and all those standing watch for
america
we have so much
to do
it's within our capacity to do it
we just have to remain steadfast
steadfast
we will complete our mission
and we will continue
after our troops have withdrawn
to find means by which we can find
any american
who wishes to get out of afghanistan
we will find them and we will get them
out so that is him admitting that
americans are going to be left behind
fully
in his daughtering and confused fashion
okay then he took a few questions from a
list
as always
and he admits right up front they gave
me a list who is they
you know have you ever heard he it's
such a weird tick and he does it nearly
all the time now they gave me a list
who your night nurse
who gave you the list
why do you have a list why can't you
just call on people
are you incapable of pointing your
finger here is joe biden explaining that
they they you know the same nice lady
who uh who who gives me my pills every
morning gave me this list here
ladies and gentlemen
they gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc the first person
i was instructed to call on what in the
actual
okay so
um one of the first questions is did you
make a mistake in working with the
taliban
and of course he's like i've never made
a mistake in my entire life
and some criticism uh even from people
in your party about the dependence on
the taliban to secure the perimeter of
the airport do do you feel like there
was
a mistake uh made in that regard
no i i don't look um
no one trusts them
we're just counting on their
self-interest
to continue
to generate their activities
and it's in their self-interest
that
we leave when we said
and that we get as many
people out as we can that last part is
just a lie why is it in their interest
that we get as many people out as we can
it's in their interest that we leave
when we say we're going to leave because
they want us out that part's true but
you already guaranteed we're leaving so
there's no countervailing factor there
if i say i'm leaving no matter what
no matter what which is what biden said
over and over and over and over again
what's the obligation on them
and by the way it is not in their
interest that everybody leaves with the
united states it's very much in their
interest that they have a bunch of
hostages that they can hold over the
head of the united states so the us
has no option but continuing to funnel
the money
and make nice with them
everybody knows this
hey now it get it it's pretty incredible
um
he has asked specifically at one point
about this political story i mentioned
earlier that the united states handed a
list essentially a kill list to the
taliban and joe biden is not with us he
is not in the loop he is not mentally
there this is an amazing unbelievable
discombobulated answer
so yes there have been occasions like
that
and to the best of my knowledge
in those cases
the bulk of that has occurred they've
been let through
but i can't tell you with any certitude
that there's actually been a list of
names i know there may have been but i
know of no circumstance it doesn't mean
it's not didn't exist
that here's the names of 12 people that
come and let them through that could
very well have happened that very well
could have happened you're the president
of the united states of america
isn't it of relevance to you whether the
us military under your direct command is
handing lists of afghans who worked with
us to the taliban
it very well could have happened
alrighty then this is just it's so
beautiful he's asked us he bear
responsibility for this and joe biden's
like this by peter ducey and um and he
says he does bear responsibility but
but
here we go
i bear responsibility for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late but here's the deal
you know
i wish you one day say these things you
know as well as i do
that the former president
made a deal with the taliban okay again
you know that it i take the blame but uh
it's trump but it's trump weird because
you said in an open interview that
whether or not trump had done anything
he would have done exactly the same
thing
and then of course he poses the false
alternative we had to do it this way
this unbelievably crappy way or we'd
have to pour thousands of more troops
into afghanistan
and also we've accomplished our
objectives which is weird because our
objective presumably was to fight
terrorism as joe biden's about to say i
noticed some terrorism yesterday against
americans
i'd have only one alternative
pour thousands of more troops back into
afghanistan
to fight a war
that we had already won relatives by the
reason we went in the first place
i have never been of the view
okay we can stop it there when he says
that we could fight pour more troops
into afghanistan to fight a war we had
already won relative to why we went and
then he later he says we went to prevent
al-qaeda from being in afghanistan well
um
you know it's preventing al-qaeda from
being in afghanistan us being there with
a skeleton crew of 2 500 people that's
what was happening okay the the lasting
images from this presser are not going
to be any of the things he said it's
just going to be the images and there
were two particular ones that came out
one was joe biden like a small child
being called on in class without having
done his homework burying his face
in the podium essentially as peter ducey
asks him a difficult question here's
what that looked like
no no no wait a minute i'm asking you a
question is that accurate the best
you're not
do you think that people have an issue
with
pulling out of that
thing
i think
they have an issue that image of the old
man clutching a binder to his chest
and lowering his head
as though he is being victimized and put
upon
after 13 american service members die in
service to his garbage mission
that is an unbelievable image and then
it finishes with um him saying he has to
leave because you know he has another
meeting for real guys for real
yes i do because look at it this way
folks and i'm gonna i have another
meeting for real i have another meeting
for real oh as opposed to for fake
this
what a disgrace he is what a disgrace he
is
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang